anaya this season
owen ii he's run out of gas in each of
his first two starts
ready to play some baseball shinsu
starting it off first pitch swinging
that ball carrying well god a home run
he's done it again chew with an ambush
on the first pitch
and it's one-nothing rangers now the
one-two fish to elvis andreas on the
outside corner ring him up one away
fastball 92 good off-speed pitch gallows
strikes out gallow likes that fastball
and that was a little slider frazier
goes that's a swing and a miss so three
strikeouts for sean manaya but the chew
home run
former first round pick of the minnesota
twins spent 10 years with the twins
before making the move to texas and
here's matt olsen
as he stands in with an average of 139
but he's taking his walks
2-2 pitch in the air to right field
gallow going back still going back
and that baby's golf gets a heater up
and the big fella does not
miss olson's second home run of the year
and the a's have a 2-1 lead
2-2 pitch and a curveball got him
swinging
gibson strikes out canna and that ends
the inning but the a strike
for two on matt olsen's second home run
of the year robbie grossman leads off
for the ace bottom of the second is two
to one a's over the rangers
the o2 breaking ball swinging a miss
kyle gibson
with the slider that dips below the bat
of grossman
ground ball towards second andrews was
there
gibson gets a couple of ground outs and
a strikeout working around the two out
base hits
and their nine batter the center fielder
scott heinemann stands in
and that's a swing and a miss on a high
fastball midnight from the stretch the
leg kick the pitch
swing and a missed and the inning is
over two strikeouts for banaya five on
the game on to the bottom of the third
2-1 oakland
top of the order due up for the a's here
in the bottom of the third 2-2
got him swinging and kyle gibson now has
three strikeouts
and the athletics have runners at first
and second with one out for matt chapman
swinging a miss chapman attacked a
fastball that was a borderline strike at
the bottom of the zone
two outs here in the bottom of the third
the a's with runners at first and second
this ball hit out to left field two
flags it down on a great running grab
in left and the inning is over that puts
men at first
and second nobody out great opportunity
here for the rangers in the top of the
fourth
this one lined out toward right field
drops in
heads to the corner and we got a foot
race frazier scores
and that ties the game at two here's
connor falefa runners at second and
third nobody out
slow chopper and a bare hand play
no play everybody's safe a run is in
and the rangers back on top 3-2 3-2
in the air right-center field a lot of
room out there loriano gets to it
tagging at third solac
he scores sac fly for ruff snyder
and he makes it 4-2 rangers and that sac
fly looks like it's going to knock shawn
minaya out of this game
burt smith he's been loosening for a
while he's ready to go
he's back with a 2-2 and that's popped
up shallow left going out of simeon
coming in grossman robbie's there he'll
make the catch the ending is over and
that'll bring up joey gallo
struck him out high fastball gallow has
struck out three times all swinging
more action for marcus simeon
after a four and a half the rangers lead
the as4 too austin allen leads out for
the a's they have some work to do we go
to the bottom of the fifth
swing and a miss allen strikes out to
begin the fifth inning and that's six in
a row now retired
by gibson the 2-2
strike three code over the inside corner
a changeup
from gibson might have gotten a little
bit of a wider zone
so two out bottom of the fifth here's
laureano
hit pretty well to center heinemann back
heinen's still going back
and that baby's gone that's center field
for ramon laureato for his third home
run of the year
and now the ends are down four to three
hard on the ground one knee kind of full
up that will hop up and make the play
nicely done
bottom of the sixth inning rangers lead
by one it will be the heart of the order
though for oakland
and chapman swings and misses chasing a
breaking ball below the zone
and gibson with strikeout number eight
here tonight
that strike three called and gibson
claps his hands with some authority
in what might be his final act of the
night here's austin allen he's won for
13 on the season he's the left-hand
hitting catcher
high in the air to right center tipped
pretty well
and that baby's gone
aisley first career home run for
austin allen a high towering shot
right-hander luke farrell comes out of
the bullpen to work for the ranger as we
go to the bottom of the 8th inning
first pitch swinging matt olson hits one
very high
center field and that baby is gone
a little insurance run to deep right
center on the first pitch ferrell throws
and olson has a two homer game
here's ref schneider with two out in the
ninth one two pitch strike three called
and that's how the ball game ends with a
strikeout